you  the students were here every day Monday  through Friday for four weeks each  student during that time was in a  smaller ensemble I had a musicianship  that is theory any theory kind of class  learning music theory many of them also  had another ensemble activity the  students wanted to hear the teachers  perform now our teachers were who were  there every day were a combination of  New Haven public school teachers and  school of music students or recent grads  they did a whole really wonderful  variety of of different performances the  students really made  a great stride of a great amount of  progress 150 people in the audience for  the final event which I just thought was  great and these are families probably  that most of whom have never known that  there is a wonderful concert hall called  Sprague Memorial Hall sitting sitting  here in an ovl campus so it was great to  see them in the hall and descend to see  the pride on their faces as they saw  their youngsters perform